hey what's up guys my name is a general
welcome to episode 15 of game
programming so yesterday we made an FPS
counter which you'll see if I run the
program it yeah we basically made a
timer and an FPS counter and you'll
actually see the effect of the timer and
of the update method um of how that's
actually rolling you'll see that users
are later I can't really show you now
but nevertheless that is very important
to our code don't worry although not all
this code is actually being put into use
right now it will be eventually so just
just hold your breath and it'll it'll be
done and we're sitting at around 3,000
frames per second so just keep that in
mind when we're rendering one pixel so
what I mean is that that that read 3,000
frames per second is going to go down
okay
just keep that in mind so today we're
actually going to take a big step
forward and actually render a map yep
that's right I just went from like a
black screen and one pixel into a whole
map but now by map I don't mean like a
full like ridiculous map I mean just
basically a bunch of tiles of different
of different color and we'll just render
them to fill the screen that's all we're
going to do there and um
and it'll be it'll look really cool and
will actually visibly be able to see I
guess what our game is going to
potentially look like which is um which
is awesome so let's jump into right now
so I told you last time that this x time
and stuff variables which is to
demonstrate you know how this works with
that one pixel which is going to get rid
of them right now so get rid of that
yeah if you write it down and get rid of
all this counter stuff and get rid of no
no don't get rid of that but change this
Y time less than zero to just Y is less
than zero and same with greater than
height same with X just get rid of X
just tap change X time two x and y time
2y and
when you run up what you should get is
just the pure pink screen at this point
which is which is what we get which is
brilliant so now we actually have to
render I guess a tile map and the way
we're going to do that is actually
really really simple we just need to set
up an array that keeps track or get I
guess get actually puts data into every
tile on our screen so the first thing
we'll do is we'll just actually just set
up like a size for our map right so how
big we want it to be
I'm just going to say look we're going
to make a map that's 64 64 tiles wide
and 60 4 tiles high so 64 by 64 so what
we'll do is we'll actually just create
public in still be an integer and we'll
just call it tiles and array of integers
rather and I'll set that equal to new in
and since we agreed on 64 being the size
of just I'll just go 64 times 64 so on
it'll be 64 wide and 64 high so for a
total of you know that many tiles 64
times 64 tiles which is 4096 tiles the
publisher to known that without a
calculator but um I had a long day today
so we'll have total 4096 tiles now what
we've done here is again we've created
an array we've created one integer to
keep to keep track of each tile so each
of those 4096 tiles now we actually need
to set a color to them at this point
because we want them to render it in
different colors and the way we can do
that is actually kind of simple now
because we don't want them all to have
the same color you know we want them to
have just random colors we can actually
use Javas random class now Java's random
classes like the greatest thing you'll
ever see especially for game design and
game development it's just it's
priceless so right now I'm just going to
type private random random equals new
random that's it and I'll import it and
random number generator which is like
insane like it is it is your best friend
because here in the constructor for the
screen because remember this constructor
will only be called one so we can put
four in I equals zero I is less than our
map size which is 64 times 64 so that we
actually do do whatever's in this for
loop the amount of times as the amount
of pixels sorry the amount of tiles that
we've got on our screen i + + so again
it will do it will do what we put here
for every single tile on our screen and
we'll just set tiles i equal to random
dot next int and we'll just put 0 x FF
FF FF which is white so in other words
it will choose any available color out
of the 16 point 7 million colors from
anywhere from 0 which is black to white
and obviously every color in between
that to add to our tiles and I'll just
randomly generate a color for us and
then put that value of that color that
number of that color into the specific
tile index so now what we've done now is
we've created 4096 tiles and they all
have a color applied to them a random
color applied to them which means every
time we launch our game that color will
actually change it'll be different so
now we've done that we actually need to
render render this this stuff and to
render it um we need to actually do a
few things so this code isn't exactly
going to render it what we actually need
to do is make sure that we're rendering
um you know what actually does we could
probably just do it this way I'm not
going to confuse you guys too much so
I'm just gonna create a brand new
integer called tile index and this is
just going to basically find the tile
that needs to be rendered at a
particular position okay so in other
words if our screen is up to rendering
out in our halfway halfway into the
screen right the screen class is
rendering all of our tiles and it's like
up to a specific tile it knows which
tile it actually has to retrieve this
color information from so it knows which
index or which element of our tiles
array it actually needs to retrieve
the color data from
to find out what kind of qatal it is and
the way we can work that out is actually
very simple what we need to do is search
for the X because remember it's going to
be rendering throughout our entire
screen but the problem is we have if we
go back into here we see that we have
300 pixels for our width right 300 but
an Emer and you might be like hang on
isn't as in our width 64 well yeah but
the thing is tiles aren't one pixel wide
and one pixel that then up one by one
pixel that would be stupid
they're like I don't know there they
have a size to them either like 8/8 size
so 8 by 8 or 16 or 32 bits or 8 by 8 is
16 by 16 32 by 32 64 by 64 etc so what
we need to we need to do at this point
is actually decide what how big our
tiles should be and what I'm going to do
for this series is just leave them at 32
30 so that will be our tile size 32 by
32 pixels is one tile simple as that
okay
I'm not putting them to high resolution
because I don't want to have to draw
graphics and such a high resolution and
also there's just I don't know I think a
little bit better at a lower resolution
and then again I'm not going to pop it
down to eight because I still want to be
able to draw things that relative that
look like you know real-life objects not
just a bunch of pixels on top of each
other so um generally 32 is a good size
so what we need to do is actually
multiply X by 32 and the reason is you
know what we want to do is say that okay
we're up to number two in X right but
the problem is it's West
on the same tile right because we want
the first 32 pixels of our X to be the
same color because because those 32
pixels are still one tile and then when
we go on to the 33rd pixel yep that's
already number two tile in our worth
thing and you'll actually see this in a
minute when I demonstrate it um + and
again this is kind of the same as this
like it's pretty much exactly the same
as this so we need to do the same thing
for y so just Y times 32 and then we
multiplied it by width here so here we
actually need to multiply it by the map
width which is 64 so all that multiplied
by 64 and what this will do is actually
find the correct tile for a coordinate
on the screen okay - marvelous piece of
technology so what we what we want to do
now is pretty damn simple we just want
to say okay instead of our pixels which
is remember the pixels that actually get
displayed onto our screen instead of
having them equal a solid color which is
in this case pink we actually want it to
equal that specific tile at that tile
index so all we need to do here is
instead of display the one color which
is pink we can put tile which is
referring to our tile of the tiles array
so it's called tiles not tile and then
we can the index of that will actually
just be the tile index and that's it
simple as that so now if we hit the
debug button we'll crash
and the reason we crashed I actually
didn't expect that so yay
around excited bounds exception alright
my favourite exception and it's actually
it's pretty simple
hmm whatever crash
I'm probably going to say it's something
to do oh well I'm kind of stupid I just
taught you guys the wrong thing it's not
x 32 it's divided by 30 to go ha time in
a year
sorry long bad guys I'm not kidding um
who I had a theater studies monologue
performance today in front of like three
BCAA examiners which was kind of I don't
know I didn't feel nervous at all I just
went there and had some fun but um yeah
I don't know anyway though I'm so glad
that's over but yeah you know I'm sure
you can excuse me so home to play what
was I thinking
now default divided by 32 is going to do
is basically say that the first 32
pixels of X is going to it's going to
refer to refer to one tile so when X is
up to from zero when the X pixel is up
to is up from 1 to 32 or from 0 to 31
more like if it's from 0 to 32 it will
be one tile and then from 33 to 64 will
be another tile from an etc it'll just
keep going like that so you know from
from 0 64 to 96 it'll be another tile 96
to 128 will be another will be another
tile so I'm basically what we're saying
is we're divided by dividing by 32
because tiles are 32 by 32 size so if we
launch our game now what we should see
is a bunch of tiles now they're actually
very big so having second thoughts about
making them that big
all right and you can see that up our
FPS is slightly down it's not down too
much it was hovering around 2000 it's
still around 2000 so it's not about it
did go up to 3000 though but um yeah so
you can see that we've actually got a
bunch of random tiles and if you
remember the color of this but like a
dark green here in a light green here if
I just really launched this look at that
it's changed because they are randomly
generated now what you can do is reduce
this size to something like 16 and
you'll actually see them be a lot
smaller you can see here they're half
the size and I'm probably just going to
keep it at that actually I think that um
32 is a bit of a long shot let me know
in the comments what size you think I
should keep it out 60 16 or 32 because
I'm I don't know it's up to you guys and
the other thing is one more like really
really small optimization that we can
make because this is going to be
rendered so many times it's actually
going to be a slightly faster to use a
bitwise operator here especially because
16 is actually a multiple of two so
because 16 is a multiple of 2 X divided
by 16 is the same as X shifted right 4
places sorry 3 places
no 4 places my bad I'm probably going to
keep it at 16 um and the reason this is
is a shifted right is the same thing as
dividing and then this number is just
true to the power of this so in other
words this is the same X shifted right 4
places armed it's a bit operation is the
same as X divided by 16 because 2 to the
power of 4 is 16 and this shifted right
means divided by okay and we'll do the
same thing here as well and we'll launch
our game and I'm getting a call right
now but it can't answer it and you can
uh well firstly you can see that we're
actually running much faster I say that
as a drop but um we are running slightly
faster which is good but what what I'm
what I'm saying is if you're in if
you're in quite a like if you're in
quite a loop especially like a nested
for loop
and and you're using multiples of two
and you're dividing or multiplying why
don't use bitwise operators it's going
to be faster so yeah anyway guys that's
going to wrap it up for this episode we
got we got to this which is actually
quite some progress and tomorrow we'll
actually explore a few more things with
this and actually maybe add some some
inputs so we can actually navigate
around this randomly generated color map
um and and yeah so I'll see you guys
tomorrow if you like this video please
hit the like button and yeah we're
probably on keep it at sixteen by
sixteen size pixels and tiles pixels and
yeah anyway I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you